i also love that you're a gamer yeah i
am yes i love i love hosting it more
than playing
but although i got to tell you weakest
link that i'm now
um hosting i love this game
and can i tell you why yes the reference
level
it's it's based on a bbc quit the bbc
quiz show format
the reference level of the questions
it's you know no offense to hollywood
game night which i loved
but most of those questions were pop
culture and you had to read people
magazine in order to do well
but you kind of have to have a general
knowledge
and some education in order to
uh you know do well on weakest link and
every round the questions get harder so
every show is not only dramatic and
fun it's an education and i
love that are you practicing your you
are the weakest link
oh you betcha looking right into the
mirror now of course i'm not going to
imitate ann robinson that would be
absurd and impossible and i'd be setting
myself
up for failure so i'm doing my own
version of it
and i'm enjoying it very much we've been
doing a lot of zoom rehearsals so i've
gotten to
practice it multiples multiple times
well let's take a look who thinks vin
diesel
is a fossil fuel it's time to vote off
the weakest link
[Music]
we will all be watching here the royal
we
the actual we all of us will be there
and you're right it is trivia it's
actually brain food it's empowering it's
enlightening it's entertaining it's
everything
it's all of that oh my gosh you should
do our press that's exactly what it is
it's brain food i love it i'm gonna
probably use that but i will credit you
um would you ever consider uh coming
back to the show and i feel like i'm
putting you on the spot now
but how about this ruminate marinate
soak in this idea of
just doing some stuff with christy
cummings and
i'd love to i because we want to play on
this show i love carol burnett and i
love old variety
and sketch so if you will ever do
anything with me yes
i would love to okay we should do a
little sketch together that would be
fun
[Laughter]
oh my god i will be yeah oh that's i am
rhapsody and white i'll get my like
poodle balls on i'll get a summer cut
the whole nines
oh fantastic oh thank you jade
[Music]
you